welcome everyone thank you for joining
our presentation today titled lateral
flow manufacturing strategies and scale
up towards point-of-care testing it is
my pleasure to introduce to you dr chris
franzek application scientist bio dot
incorporated for a complete biography on
our speaker today please visit the tab
at the top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box our speaker will
address your questions following at the
end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr chris
fonzak i will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello i'm chris and i'm an application
scientist with biodot i'm going to be
discussing lateral flow manufacturing
strategies and scale up towards point of
care testing
a little bit about biodot we are a 26
year old privately held company we
supply systems and solutions to various
marketplaces from lateral flow
diagnostics to life sciences to clinical
we're very customer focused we're
collaborative
in nature we're very application focused
our global headquarters is in irvine
california where all of our
manufacturing and quality is done
recently we opened uh east coast of the
united states location in hillsboro
north carolina we have european office
in the uk
a chinese office in shanghai as well as
distributors worldwide
we focus on a variety of markets from
point-of-care tests to cytogenetics
molecular diagnostics and even medical
and industrial
however we really got started
in lateral flow devices
particularly in the last eight months
we've been very heavily focused
in manufacturing of cobit 19 tests
the lateral flow device manufacturing
process
can be subdivided in a couple of
different categories
first is the deposition of reagent what
i'll refer to as dispensing
this involves depositing antibody test
and control lines on nitrocellulose
membrane
treating any
sample pads or wicking pads beforehand
and depositing gold conjugate on the
conjugate pad
next is drawing of all
layers
and then assembling the layers in a
process called lamination
before cutting and assembling
lateral flow manufacturing can be
subdivided into batch manufacturing and
inline manufacturing
batch manufacturing is smaller scale
production
from
initial r d to hundreds of thousands of
devices per year inline manufacturing is
higher throughput
to millions of devices per year
and this talk will focus
not only on each one but the process of
transitioning from batch to inline
when considering
reagent deposition
there are several critical factors which
must be looked at
first and foremost is dispense volume
and accuracy
this is critical for the development of
sensitive tests
volumetric accuracy should be
within plus or minus three percent of
the desired target volume
with better than five percent drop to
drop precision
dispense position
along the membrane should also be
considered
often times
reagents must be within plus or minus 50
microns of the desired position this is
important
to avoid
region overlap
in addition to
for for example tester control line
emission because of overlap
for these more challenging applications
vision systems or fiducial markings can
be used
it's critical to avoid
cross-contamination particularly to
avoid false positives in testing this
can be accomplished through non-contact
dispensing
it's important to be able to work over a
wide range of fluid reality
from blocking buffers to gold conjugates
to antibodies
in addition to
some more viscous concentrations
typically
this process will be
over a wide dynamic range from
nanoliters to microliters per drop
of reagent
however
newer applications
including
high density microarrays and lateral
flow often require picoliter volumes
dispensing technology should be scalable
from hundreds of thousands to tens of
millions
of tests per year
it's also important to work with
different arrangement of dispense
nozzles
to create custom patterns
there are a variety of dispense
technologies
used for this reagent deposition which i
will talk about in detail
aerojet
is used
to deposit gold conjugate
biojet is used to deposit antibodies
front lines also used to deposit
antibodies the differences biojets
non-contact prolines contact
and for those aforementioned microarrays
piezo dispensing technology can be used
for those smaller volume drops
the air jet is a syringe pump driven
aerosolizer
which is used for depositing gold
conjugate onto fiberglass
it's syringe pump driven making it
highly accurate and precise
it's capable of operating over a wide
volumetric range all the way up to 24
microliter per centimeter
the flow rate is controllable and
adjustable through the adjustment of
positive air
and the spray width is adjustable
making it possible to create a more
dense or wider cone across the substrate
all of these things lend to a very
consistent aerosol
as is shown here on the left
of air jets and various arrangement
spraying gold conjugate onto fiberglass
membrane
all of these dispensers that i'm
discussing
allow for independent control of the
spence channels
which further lead to the lack or
avoidance of cross-contamination
here's an example of a
custom arrangement of air jets
used for completely impregnating
fiberglass
with different gold conjugate
air jets can also be used for
impregnation of material for blocking or
sample pre-treatment
biojets are also syringe pump driven
they are used for the deposition of
antibody testing control lines
reagent is taken from a source bottle
guided through a syringe pump
micro stepping from the syringe pump
delivers
a said volume to a solenoid
which opens and closes
based on a specified
open time
this simultaneous coordination of
microstepping and a micro solenoid
firing
creates a proper kinetic energy to break
off a drop of liquid onto a substrate
this works over
a large dispense range anywhere from two
nanoliters per drop to two microliters
per drop
working in multiple modes typically
for lateral flow development we will be
looking at on the fly
meaning drops will be deposited to
create a tight line
and motion and dispensing are
coordinated without stopping
for certain applications particularly
arrays step and repeat
is also an option
to create these patterns
where a motion is temporarily stopped
between dispensing
as with the air jet there is an
independent control over each dispense
channel
and unlike the air jet because there is
independent control over a syringe pump
sitting in a micro solenoid setting
the user can adjust
the dispenser for different fluid
realities and this is very critical for
drop morphology
reagent sources can be bulk meaning they
start from
a container
or for r d level work
the syringe pump can be reversed to
aspirate
from for example a micro tighter plate
all this lends itself to high dispense
rates
pictured on the right are four
independent
bio jet channels
these are the solenoids these are the
ceramic tips
here is a video of two bio jet channels
dispensing
test and control line on 25 millimeter
wide nitrocellulose
this is
at a fairly moderate dispense speed
this is an example of on-the-fly
dispensing where
drops are pitched tightly to create
concise lines
on the right is an example of
a raise and lateral flow
three different bio jet channels
dispensing arrays on the fly of 20
nanoliter drops
the speed shown here is 30 millimeters
per second
however
the speed can be run
at a more vigorous 60 millimeters per
second
which
is shown here
each one of these arrays would represent
a separate test
frontline technology is another type of
technology
used to deposit antibodies
unlike the biojet dispensers front line
is contact
using flexible
tips made of peak material
syringe pump delivers a quantity of
volume
in contact with the membrane and the
tips drag or glide
across the nitrocellulose
for more specialized applications piezo
dispensing can be used for example
to create multiplex lateral flow arrays
these include
arrays that are sometimes
quantitative
for a test or perhaps test which
otherwise would be ambiguous
piezo dispensing works over pico leader
to low nanoliter
range
for drop dispensed driven by a piezo
element
this is typically used to aspirate
but also can be bulk fed for certain
larger scale operations
high density arrays can be created as
shown here
and just because this is piezo does not
mean throughput is sacrificed
some advantages from this type of
dispensing
first of all are the ability to
create geometric symbols
alphanumeric symbols
and this tends to lend itself to better
quantification higher sensitivity while
lowering reagent use
in order to create these specialized
arrays
software and an easy to use
graphical user interface is often
required
a pattern can be easily created
which then leads to the creation of
these
symbols such as the one shown on the
right
when considering dispensing of reagents
it's also important to consider quality
control
during dispensing
control often requires some type of
vision application
this can be
achieved using a camera to look at
membranes during the dispensing process
as well as a bad part marker
to use some type of feedback mechanism
to blot out
any section of membrane to be discarded
later
for dispensing
these vision applications are often used
to look at line
position with and integrity
as shown here
this is critically important because
poor line integrity
can lead to ambiguous results or false
negatives
but also
line position
can lead to bleeding of reagents or
the excise or overlay of that line
during
lamination this is also very critically
important for array based applications
that require a reader window to fit on
this type of vision application can also
be used for conjugate
primarily looking at conjugate width
position and even concentration
besides dispensing vision qc
is also important during lamination
primarily
for
position and overlap
because
if the overlap is too great for example
in building up a lateral flow device
a test line can be lost or a control
line can be lost
and when considering reagent deposition
and vision
and quality control
it's important to put them in context
of batch production and inline
production
for batch production
materials are typically pre-cut to
length
membrane can be pre-laminated prior to
reagent deposition or the individual
layers
can be processed before lamination
batch production usually is in the
context of r d
to low level production typically less
than one million tests per year
developed
quality control
while sometimes automated is usually
manual
this is a picture of a batch level
system
for reagent deposition
capable of depositing antibodies on
nitrocellulose and spraying gold
conjugate through an air jet
any sample pad pre-treatment or blocking
and sometimes even conjugate
impregnation is accomplished using some
type of tray for dipping
and all materials are dried in an oven
drying is typically the rate limiting
stop
a small laminator is used to assemble
the test
to make layers as shown to the left
and a guillotine cutter is used to cut
strips to the desired length
often the goal is to start in batch
level manufacturing and once a process
is set to move to larger scale
production
however there are many things to
consider
in this transition
first of all material selection
oftentimes and this is true in cobit 19
testing
certain materials are chosen for
higher sensitivity results
however these materials are often
brittle thin and sometimes have
poor tensile strength
when considering inline manufacturing
sometimes hundred meter rolls of
materials need to be tracked
so tensile strength is very important in
addition
for web handling and tracking
the design process should transfer
easily to manufacturing
not just from a dispensing perspective
in a time perspective but also from a
process perspective
for example
transitioning time from lots a lot or
batch to batch or even application
application
and drawing
drawing again is the rate limiting step
in the batch level manufacturing
materials are often dried overnight
however in-line manufacturing drying
needs to be faster
it's also important
to use equipment that can be
transitioned easily from batch to inline
manufacturing
fortunately
the dispensers
that i discussed earlier do just that
in looking at inline high-level
manufacturing
materials are continuously fed
from a payout module to a takeout module
this is typically
using the on-the-fly dispensing that i
mentioned earlier
this provides for great process control
including continuous drawing inline qc
with vision
and precision alignment due to tracking
here we see
a series
of syringe pumps
these are tandem
meaning two pumps feed one line
this allows for continuous dispensing
while
one syringe is emptying the other one is
filling that way the process never has
to
end this is in the context of higher
volume production capabilities
for example at 50 millimeters per second
100 meters can be treated in about 34
minutes this is enough to produce 20 000
tests per year
built-in environmental controls are
possible both in the dispense module as
pictured here also to the take-up module
the whole goal of this besides
increasing throughput is to reduce
waste and to reduce qc time
here is an example of an inline
system
for dispensing and drawing
a system like this is capable of
producing up to millions and tens of
millions of tests per year
a roll of material
is fed and driven
through a series of dispensers
the dispensing is analyzed via qc
potentially with feedback
oftentimes impregnation for blocking is
included
material is fed through forced air dry
towers
and then rolled up on what we call a
take-up
in addition to the features
i just mentioned on the other slide
other features can be added depending on
application
for example for poor tensile strength
material
ultra low tension options are available
which reduce inertial force
on the membrane
humidity control
enclosures can be included around
dispensing and take a module
and for many applications
where moisture is critical a moisture
sensor can be added inline
a newer trend in inline manufacturing is
plc systems
in order for proper control monitor and
communication between each of these
modules
not only does this allow for everything
to be controlled more centrally
for example this system to this system
but also for more proper data collection
and feedback
here is a video of a reel to reel
120
feeding
nitrocellulose membrane
as shown here
being driven
through a system
of biojets dispensing
five antibody lines
these tandem pumps ensure
that the process has never stopped
now this is nitrocellulose for
conjugate
a separate process would be used on the
same system where fiberglass would be
fed to that air job
here you see five lines on
nitrocellulose
being analyzed
with inline vision
and a bad part marker before being dried
and rolled up in the takeout module
following inline region deposition the
layers are assembled into a test and a
process called lamination
auto lamination
includes web speeds up to 100
millimeters per second which is highly
dependent upon what material being run
as well as the number of laminates or
how complicated the test is
this process is designed for quick
alignment and changeover that way
multiple products can be run on a single
system
the system is modular it's flexible it
can be run with multiple applications
and these modular units can be added and
subtracted from the system later as
needed
typically
after lamination
the finished layers are fed to a cutter
for cutting
these can be first fed to master cards
in a reel
to be transferred
or cut in line
here's an example of an auto laminator
from left to right
a module
laying backing card down
before being laminated with
nitrocellulose containing anybody
testing control lines
then having a conjugate pad added
these layers can then be analyzed with
vision for overlap and precision
before being laid with cover tape or
barcode
in this scenario
either the tests are cut in a guillotine
cutter or rolled up for a downstream
process
here is a video of an auto laminator
the backing
material with the take-up liner
the membrane payout with tracking and
take-up liner
and three material layout in this case
including conjugate
the vision inspection
the cover tape payout
and placement
before the cutter
cap stand for tracking
and driving and the take-up reel
in addition to basic lamination
barcode labels can be added
for the test
and provision inspection recognition
after lamination cards can be collected
and stored instead of cutting
or the final assembled test can be
rolled up
[Music]
the last process prior to
bottling or packaging is cutting
these are a couple of the cutting
options besides the guillotine cutter
in this scenario a rolled up test can be
fed
to a cutter
to create specific lengths these cutters
can be
used
with various sensors including a target
sensor for fiducials
in this picture
a bottle collector is added to the end
of the cutter
to collect
the cut test strips
here
shown is a cutter that is used in batch
level manufacturing
pre-cut cards that are laminated
are fed to a cutter
and then bottled
in this picture
a rolled up laminated test
is being fed to a cutter
which then sorts
into two different bottles
besides the standard
lateral flow test that contain testing
control lines
it is possible to create multiplexed
arrays
and geometric symbols
besides multiplexing
this can
lead to more sensitive quantitative
tests but also qualitative tests
to
eliminate the possibility for any
ambiguity or create a certain message
multiplexing can be done at the batch
level or inline web handling
in a high throughput manner
oftentimes this is continuous however
for certain complicated arrays indexing
is important
at a high speed
that
enables multiple arrays per second to be
created
region handling is critical
in particular
oftentimes higher concentrations or more
viscous samples are required
typically
this process is going to be using
picoliters to nanoliters
as opposed to microliters
as shown here
in 50 nanoliter spots on nitrocellulose
positional accuracy is very critical for
this particularly
for multiplex arrays or require some
type of reader
for this reason fiducials can be used
often with a vision system
and software is used for
editing an array which is particularly
ideal
when looking at r d level manufacturing
here is an example of batch level
multiplex array
which include pre-cut card
various dispense channels dispensing an
array
created
your revision program
this process can also be adapted to
in-line manufacturing
often times with the ring for example
here is a schematic or a concept
of material being fed into two separate
dispense modules for indexing to create
these
more complex arrays
before being dried
this concept also shows in line
lamination
and cutting and bottling
which would be the ideal process
oftentimes
customers choose to separate these out
that way
multiple
lots
in addition to multiple tests
can be developed
when looking at multiplexed arrays
particularly in smaller volumes
qc is
especially important for inline
manufacturing
because it's critical to know exactly
when to make a cut and when to dispense
arrays
for this reason fiducial markings are
also used
these
fiducial markings
not only allow
a cutter to trigger cuts
as needed down the process as well as
lamination
but can also be used to trigger
dispensers
to
deposit a very specific pattern
within a certain window
thank you for your time
and thank you dr forensic
for that outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation and as a
reminder please submit your questions uh
in the q and a box
okay
our first question is
um can you give some specific examples
of arrayed lfds
um
so array lfds are not nearly as common
as the standard lfds stripes with single
lines however typically we'll see
multiplex
tests that
require a higher level of sensitivity
that can be matched up with some sort of
a reader
and one of the big advantages of the
array
is that the customer
can use less reagent and also save costs
on the test uh in particular i have
worked with a couple of these type of
irate lfds in the past that deal with
the detection of certain toxins such as
anthrax
wow okay thank you for that
and the next question that we have is
what have what has been the biggest
challenges when manufacturing cobia 19
tests
so the nice thing about our dispensing
technology
is that
going from different types of tests
different types of biochemistries is
often directly translatable since we can
kind of tune for different fluid uh
realities and properties
in all reality the biggest
challenge that we faced is customers who
are pretty new to this arena to lfd type
of tests jumping into the covet arena
with
some of them little experience
uh the other part of that will be a lot
of customers who
have been more in r d
type of manufacturing jumping to inline
for cova testing so it's mainly been
assisting customers kind of making that
jump in a very short period of time
which has been very common in the last
eight months as you can imagine
thank you so much dr funzak and i have a
few more questions here uh
how many tests per year are possible
when batch manufacturing
uh typically and this is really heavily
dependent upon the actual process
we have seen
a single system manufacturing in the low
to mid hundreds of thousands of tests
per year
um in order to really get closer to the
million tests per year it usually
requires
uh maybe three ships a day and often
multiple pieces of equipment and at some
point it usually makes more sense to
just scale to to the inline
type of equipment for that
so usually it's gonna be in the in the
low to mid hundreds of thousands maybe
up to about 500 000
thank you so much and
our fourth question today is what is the
most challenging lfa application
bio dot has experienced
so typically it's going to be
one of two scenarios
number one
it's often pretty common to select
certain materials particularly
very thin on back nitrocellulose which
is often good
for higher sensitive type of tests
transitioning from batch to inline where
web handling is critical
using those type of materials with
tensile strength is is challenging
uh the other challenge is
and really kind of what i mentioned the
talk of the the time limiting step is
drawing particularly when when
depositing a high volume of reagent
so often a challenge is
to
find a scenario where we can keep a very
high throughput but also making sure
materials are tracked properly materials
do not break in line
and materials are dried before they are
assembled in a single test
thank you so much and our last two
questions there here is what is
typically the biggest challenge when
transitioning from
batch to inline manufacturing
uh
pretty much
the
the answer i just gave uh it
it's mainly drawing um but but really
developing the process around
continuously uh processing
tests for you know an hour or so as
opposed to doing batches it's really
adapting a process and making sure that
that when developing a batch process
it's
easily translatable to in line without
having to go and reinvent the
reinvent the wheel
wonderful
okay and our final question today uh is
how common doctor forensic is it to
combine dispensing laminating and
cutting into a single inline process
the answer is it's not very common
usually lamination and cutting
are combined
the problem again usually is drawing
sufficiently
particularly when running at a higher
speed for good throughput
uh the other thing is is that a lot of
times customers are running multiple
types of tests so it doesn't make sense
to have everything in line that way they
can easily switch over to what has to
dispense
and then at the same time they can be
laminating and cutting for another type
of test if that kind of makes sense so
usually it's not very efficient plus
um an inline system that combines all
three would be very long
so it work it would require
quite a bit of space usually instead of
having a nice you know long
process like that it usually makes sense
to stack systems side by side for space
purposes
thank you again dr franzak and
unfortunately we are out of time for
today
if you have any questions that were
submitted and not answered today uh by
our speaker we'll be addressed via email
and
thank you for your outstanding questions
to the audience and the presentation
will be available on demand for viewing
in for 12 months please remember to
share it with colleagues who might be
interested in today's topic
and don't miss out on other
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda tab in the auditorium for a full
listing thank you again for your
participation and until next time
thank you